an explosion on the outskirts of kiev
sends a ripple of fear through ukraine's
capital the situation is
pretty difficult
at night we hear
constant shooting and explosions
we can occasionally
hear explosions right
like the one
you hear now
the streets are empty people have been
told to stay indoors
so we were urged by the authorities to
stay at home
in order not in order for them
to see who is
on the streets
and perhaps to locate
and distract the
uh diversions groups so today
the streets of kiev are empty the shops
are closed
uh the with keith continues actually
alexi stops filming as his daughter
calls to ask him to go to a bomb shelter
further east there's been heavy fighting
in the second city of kharkiv
i could hurt the
the gun fires the
challenge again and
different sort of
sounds of street fights on the street
people were hiding inside this night
many families with kids will have to go
down to the shelters we'll have to go
again to the underground and spend the
night there
the sounds of play and laughter would
usually fill this nursery
now an unexploded grad rocket juts from
the playground
and a child too scared to say where she
is in ukraine had this message
i constantly hear sirens
everywhere
and there's a male voice telling like to
go to a shelter
hide somewhere because
there can be a bomb possibly dropping
dropping
it's really scary
a new reality on the ground
and no one knows how many more sleepless
nights they'll have to endure
laura about a manly al jazeera